so I'm learning two things here I'm
learning that you're a big old drama
queen the world's always over yeah and
secondly your mother should be an acting
coach she you were like a life coach
Saoirse Ronan I am so excited to have
you on Fandango frontrunners you know
how much I love this movie I basically
start crying every time I talk about it
yeah second you cry right now it very
well could happen my sense is that never
before have you felt so in sync with a
character that you've played as far as
the connection between her aylesh and
your real life right because you had
moved away to London right before you
started shooting yeah yeah like nine
months before we started shooting I
moved away and I was still really really
homesick and I really as she says in the
film I really missed being an Irish girl
in Ireland and you never know when it's
gonna hit you you never know when
homesickness is gonna hit you so
unpredictable and yeah it was something
that I really was experiencing in such a
big big way when we made the film and it
just meant that emotionally there was no
separation there was no kind of escapism
at all you know because it was how I was
feeling anyway so there were points
where you kind of thought oh god am I
even acting now you know because it just
felt it felt like it was gonna
completely overwhelm you sometimes but
you got the part before you had moved
away so in a way you needed that time to
pass before you actually shot it at that
time I related to it because my mom and
dad had made that journey themselves
back in the 80s so that was kind of my
connection to us and you know they moved
over there they lived in the Bronx for
1011 years and they worked and that's
what they did and it really is you know
the most special place on earth to them
because that was the city that made them
who they are now and you know New York
is a tough place when you don't have a
lot of money or you do have to work
every day in order to kind of survive
there and that's what they did and I
mean it is very very universal the story
but it is a woman's story and there's so
much to tell there is this character has
so many principles and she's very
and secure and who she is and my mom is
that way too you know
she just encouraged me she just trusts
me you know I want to take a look at a
scene from Brooklyn and this is one of
the moments that just kills me every
time I watch this movie and this is a
montage where you actually don't speak
it's just you reading these letters and
it's so powerful I want to take a look
and ask you some questions about it okay
dear aylesh is hard for me to believe
that you're even this in America
thousands of miles across the sea
the big news here is that since you left
mommy has stopped shopping at nettles
Kenny's as you know her bread wasn't
always fresh did she overcharged for
everything and she's awful are we seeing
a leash are we seeing Saoirse who are we
looking at with all of this emotion on I
was just gonna say I'm so glad you
paused it there because I don't even
really missing home at the minute to
watch it to watch it again like it
affects you oh really Jolson and so yeah
I was reading that letter and on set
that day and I thought of my mom is
there a way that she helped encourage
you and inspire you to take this role
yeah she went through this journey she
did this so yeah it's this is very much
a film to honor her I think okay yeah
let's finish this montage here I haven't
told her to her face
there's no need she knows that she
overcharges on our bread is not fresh
we talk about you every evening of
course we want to know everything I'm
sure you're busy but even if your
letters were 200 pages they wouldn't be
long enough for your mother okay I love
your eyes there that is such a beautiful
shot it's just so great because I feel
like so much of the beauty of your
performances in your facial expressions
was that something you really worked
hard to feel like you were getting right
for this character yeah of course but I
think I've always been really drawn to
just telling a story through my eyes I
suppose and I remember again my mom said
it to me when I was younger I had just
come off of Atonement and I went on to
another phone then straight afterwards
and I said to mom you know I don't
really have any aliens and this and I
don't really get to say anything and I
remember she said to me back then she
said you can tell a whole story just
with your face and you don't have to say
a thing
and I remembered she said that to me and
it's so interesting because I think
that's something that I'm really drawn
to when it comes to expressing a
character's emotion I actually I'm at
the stage now where I would prefer to
cut lines that I have instead of over
explain things to work oh so do you feel
like making this movie helped you
through what could have been a really
tough time oh my god you are getting sad
it just means so much just the fit yeah
that's why the film means so much
because it did it got me through that
and yeah I felt like I really had grown
after that and and the homesickness
wasn't as bad anymore I love hearing
that it's my favorite movie of the year
I've said that 50 times and they keep
saying it thank you for making it and
thank you for sharing how personal it is
to you all right appreciate thanks for
almost make me cry I'm sorry okay I
won't do that ever again I swear if you
out there have not seen Brooklyn first
of all what's wrong
get your tickets on Fandango it's a
beautiful film thanks so much to the TCL
Chinese Theatre IMAX for having us today
and
thank you for watching Fandango
frontrunners
you